it's been quite a year for actress
Alison Brie besides getting Golden Globe
and SAG nominations for her role in the
hit Netflix series glow she's currently
co-starring in two major motion pictures
her latest project is the Steven
Spielberg directed drama the post it
centers on the Washington Post decision
to publish top-secret government
information from the Pentagon Papers
back in 1971 it stars Tom Hanks as the
post legendary editor Brenda Leigh and
Meryl Streep as the newspapers publisher
Katherine Graham Allison plays Graham's
eldest daughter lolly here is a peek
these be your people McNamara Kennedy
and Johnson Jack and Linden where your
father's friends you flew down to Texas
with Linda in the weekend after all you
wanted to see his helicopter the instant
I saw you we invited you to the ranch
oh well you just wanted the paper to
endorse yes but my point is you had
Steven Beale waiting at home who had
houseguests waiting at the farm got
nothing but dirty clothes in your
suitcase jumped on Air Force One Spencer
I did not it's hard to say no to the
President of the United States
Allison breed good morning to you what a
great morning with Meryl Streep I
incredible that's the first scene I shot
in this movie yeah yeah I mean the movie
really is it's an of course a story
about the press and the importance of a
free press at a time of power grabbing
yeah but it's really a portrait of
Katharine Graham an extraordinary woman
absolutely by another extraordinary
actor absolutely what was it like for
you it was incredible I think what
you're talking about really is part of
what I really loved about the story is
it's an incredible feminist story
looking at Katharine Graham who was the
first woman to run a fortune 500 company
and you know what we see in this movie
is her really coming into her own and
embracing that power for a long time
she was very on
certainly yeah a king over that position
he had never really done anything like
no no I mean she took over the position
just to keep the paper in the family and
it wasn't really she didn't think she
was making a feminist statement at the
time will you see you with Meryl Streep
on screen but behind the camera yes
Steven Spielberg yes which is no less
intimidating this old job for me was
really just about nerve management in
ways of just just play it cool be cool
but they both of them couldn't be
lovelier and Steven you know after
directing so many films he still is so
excited yeah on set and so in the moment
with you as a director that that felt I
mean it's just so exciting and palpable
he comes in so prepared that scene he
watched us rehearse it and in the middle
of us reading through the dialogue he
said stop everything this changes
everything I'm gonna change how I wanna
shoot it don't say another word Wow
doesn't like to rehearse which is kind
of refreshing and interesting when I
when I first got the part I found out
that I got it my agents called me ten
minutes later I got a call from Steven
Spielberg and you know it's on your cell
phone yeah I just saw my cell phone
numbers I don't know I was like Oh pick
it up I don't pick it up I guess maybe
Steven Spielberg on the line I'll take
that call okay I guess I have time and
it was one of the first thing you know
congratulations on the role we're very
excited he gave me a few notes about the
character and then just said you know I
don't like to rehearse yeah so I'll see
you on set in two months amazed and I
prepared unlike I had ever prepared for
anything before
tell us how you heard about found out
about your Golden Globe nomination well
I was very exciting I was actually
running late for work I was running out
of the house and I you know ran back
into the bedroom to kiss my husband
goodbye and he actually was streaming it
on his cell phone I sat down on the bed
gave him a kiss goodbye and as we pulled
apart Sharon Stone said my name and we
both froze and then just started
screaming you know it was that moment of
great moment it was unbelievable Shiki
the character you play on glo Allison
for those of us who came to know you
you're in as Trudy Campbell and an admin
the greatest television series of all
time other than Glo until now exactly
you got a perm now yeah yeah we've seen
you in some scenes that would not have
been that would have been out of yeah
yeah a lot less clothing in general than
Trudy wore that's that junk bin Oh
phenomenal I think after working on Mad
Men and also want to show community on
NBC that many years I was looking to
shake things up and do something a
little different and this couldn't be
more different than anything you could
imagine it we're wrestling you are also
in a film called the disaster artist yes
which is about the making of a movie
that many consider the worst movie of
all time yes it's it's the best worst
movie ever made and you are in it with
your husband Dave Franco who is the
brother of James Franco yes who stars in
it and also directed it it's very
confusing yes it was a good experience
yes a very good experience and very
bizarre I don't know if you've seen
pictures of James as this character but
he's playing a real guy tommy was oh who
looks like a vampire and he has facial
prosthetics and long black hair and he
basically stayed in character the entire
time we were shooting with a strange
Eastern European accent my first day on
set I walk into the room and James is
completely naked and is walking around
the set for the scene for the rain for
the art and it's like he's totally nude
and he's screaming at the crew which
then I realize is the crew that's in the
movie there's a separate crew shooting
the movie that he's also directing it
was like the most meta bizarre moment
and it was kind of like oh so this is
what this movie is gonna be also welcome
to the Frank okay thank you my friend
and congratulations on all of your say
great watching right here good luck with
the Golden Globes and the SAG Award
thank you the post opens in select
cities next Friday and nationwide on
January 12